en venant à l'article 23 bis et cher
jean lassalle je crois que vous avez là
la parole oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mais chaque hall ce
sera beaucoup plus bref ce coup ci
puisque j'ai accompli la première partie
de ma mission
lors d'une intervention dans
l'amendement
je voulais simplement dire combien ces
organismes étaient importants pour le
logement social
et combien le logement social était
importante au des communes territoriales
qui n'avait sans elle
aucun moyen aujourd'hui de construire du
logement mais on se plaint souvent que
les communes ne construisent pas
suffisant de logements
je suis social je suis maire d'une
commune qui aujourd'hui à 50 % de sa
population qui vit en logement social le
reste et il ya même des paysans qui
vivent en logement social et même des
bergers voiliers qui sont très attachés
à la montagne à la nature et c'est pas
du tout nouvelles choses ça amène une
mixité de la population qui n'est pas
toujours facile à gérer et il faut le
reconnaître une territoire très rural et
montagnard mais qui est très valorisante
puis très enthousiasmante et nous
n'aurions pas pu le faire ça c'est
sophie cela et je veux dire aussi que ce
pas un problème de trouver du terrain
quand on peut en trouver on trouve moi
j'ai construit la plupart des logements
sociaux juste devant ma maison familiale
donc voyez que ce n'est pas un problème
non plus et pas de problème de
cohabitation nos enfants se sont élevées
avec des enfants qu'il n'aurait jamais
connu
s'il n'y avait pas eu des logements
sociaux je voulais simplement rendre ce
témoignage parce que c'est une manière
aussi un petit peu légères de parler
d'un problème qui est très lourd et qui
préoccupe aujourd'hui énormément notre
pays celui du logement et celui de la
capacité de vivre ensemble
merci monsieur la salle